we have an absolute national competition
underway there are mayors across the
entire country that are competing to be
more bitcoin friendly if we go back to
november 2nd earlier this week i tweeted
out something pretty innocent i actually
tweeted it while we were on this show i
said it is time who is going to be the
first american politician to accept
their salary in bitcoin now i shot this
off and i figured that it would start a
little bit of a conversation maybe
somebody would ask a politician would
they do it we'd see where it went
almost immediately literally within
about 30 minutes less than 30 minutes
mayor francis soares of miami came off
the top rope he quote tweeted it and he
said i'm going to take my next paycheck
100
in bitcoin problem solved at saurosti
who is the cio of miami can you help now
that set off an absolute explosion the
mayor of miami the next paycheck one
paycheck he was going to take in bitcoin
the first politician in the united
states to do so well of course the newly
elected mayor of new york city the
financial capital of the world eric
adams he's not going to be outdone by
the miami mayor he came in and he said
in new york we always go big so i'm
gonna take my first three paychecks in
bitcoin when i become mayor new york
city is gonna be the center of the
cryptocurrency industry and other
fast-growing innovative industries just
wait so now we got a little friendly
competition going we got the mayor of
miami with the mayor of new york one is
going to take one paycheck the next
gonna take three well
my friend francis soares he's not gonna
be outdone by that
he
first was very congratulatory so touche
congrats on the election i look forward
to the friendly competition in making
our respective cities a crypto capital
very very nice
while he was contemplating his next move
we then saw mayor scott conger from the
city of jackson tennessee ain't nobody
ever heard of jackson tennessee but now
i know all about jackson tennessee he
said while state law prohibits the city
of jackson tennessee from paying me and
bitcoin i'll follow the lead of francis
suarez and eric adams and instantly
convert my next paycheck to bitcoin and
so now all of a sudden within two days
we got three mayors all competing to see
who could be more bitcoin friendly but
the mayor of miami was not going to be
outdone he said listen i like tennessee
i like new york city but
no no no
last night he went on television he said
he will now take 100 of his salary in
bitcoin 100 every paycheck he is gonna
take in bitcoin so again it's almost
like they're one-upping each other one
upping one upping one upping and then
this morning
as if
one and two are outliers three begins a
trend
four
that kind of breaks the dam open
and this morning we saw the tampa
bay mayor
jane castor has announced that she will
accept her pay in bitcoin as well and so
now we have four mayors across the
united states just this week who all
have decided to take part or all of
their salary
in bitcoin
and so what we are about to watch
is that not only do you have mayors who
are literally competing with each other
to say i am more bitcoin friendly than
the next one move to my city come here
we want the entrepreneurs we want the
innovators we want the investors we want
bitcoin enthusiasts we want the people
who believe in these same ethos and in
this technology
that is ultimately good for the world in
my opinion because now what you have is
you have politicians that are competing
right now simply in a social capital
type of way they're trying to prove to
you that they really believe they're
trying to prove to you that they
actually are aligned with these ethos as
well but ultimately that social capital
ends up being converted to actual action
over a long period of time because if
not people will eventually understand
that it was all talk and no action i'm
all about that action boss
but what were you going to watch is
these politicians are going to have to
start doing all sorts of different
things will they lower tax rates will
they create sandboxes of innovation will
they start to lend city resources or or
use their city resources to help
entrepreneurs and investors will they go
and pre-negotiate some sort of space
will they do things around events or
other types of activities that can help
people be more successful
there's two types of local politics
going on right now in this country the
first is people actively cheering
against the entrepreneurs and the
investors cheering against the
capitalistic society and then there are
local politicians who understand that
america was built on capitalism it was
built on job creation and on economic
prosperity but the way you get that is
not through a top-down or centrally
planned economy instead it's to simply
give the resources and needs to
entrepreneurs and investors and then get
the hell out of the way
and so when we have competition now four
cities all
east of the mississippi
it's going to become quite interesting
to see who's going to be the first to
actually start to put some of this into
action taking your salary is one thing
but who's actually going to be able to
convince more and more and more people
to move to their city because bitcoin is
going to continue to be adopted john
when you saw the mayor's competing now
is this just funny to you or do you
think that there's actually stuff that
will happen in terms of action uh coming
out of this i think it's cool i think
it's it's smart for them if they're
really gonna embrace bitcoin the way
they want to um and have said they were
especially eric adams who just recently
got elected and then mayor schwartz as
well who just won his re-election um
look they're they're putting their money
where their mouth is right they're
actually taking their
hard-earned dollars and converting them
to bitcoin um and i believe swords is
doing that via strike but it's it's
interesting to see we'll see when uh and
if they actually
ever try to hold bitcoin on the bounty i
know there's a lot of rules around that
you're not allowed to do that but we'll
see it's good for them good for bitcoin
and um hopefully they can orange pill
some more people joey you think i think
uh some people saw what mayor suarez was
doing and are trying to replicate it in
some capacity right not only with
bitcoin but just the strategy around
marketing your city right like the
ability to go on twitter online on
social media and in the public and just
publicly market your city as a good
place to live inviting people to come
there uh try to foster innovation and
bitcoin is certainly a part of that and
the ability to say hey look i'm actually
doing this personally i'm taking my own
money my own salary in bitcoin certainly
speaks to part of that and people
believe it and they see it uh but i
think ultimately it comes down to what
you said which is like how far does this
go do you do you put bitcoin on the
balance sheet do you pay city employees
in bitcoin do you give uh preferred tax
treatment to companies that come here
for innovative services or building
innovative products right so there's a
million different things those are just
a few examples but i think what we're
going to see is this is kicking off a
revolution almost of people competing
against each other which ultimately is
the best thing right competition uh
helps everyone at the end of the day so
i think what we'll see is there's gonna
be a bunch of different cities it's not
just new york it's not just miami it's
not just tampa i bet we see a bunch of
different mayors pop up and try to cater
to their citizens
miami new york la uh other places that
are like large metropolises they have a
whole bunch of different things that
they can go pitch people on hey come to
miami because there's nice weather come
because there's tax uh regime that's
friendly to you come because there's the
beach come because uh we have uh great
diversity from all of these people who
come to this uh place we have an
international airport right we have
major sports teams like you have all
these other things and oh by the way
we're bitcoin friendly or we're crypto
friendly
what i think is really interesting is
when you start to get places like
jackson tennessee which again i don't
know very much about never heard of them
before right they start to raise their
hand and say hey maybe we don't have
professional sports teams or maybe we
don't have an international airport
maybe they do but i'm just saying it
right if they didn't oh by the way we
don't have a beach oh by the way we
don't necessarily have some crazy uh uh
advantageous tax regime or a beat or uh
some sort of better weather but we're
bitcoin friendly it now is a thing that
you literally can plug your city into
the network and i think that to me is so
interesting is because once you start to
think about how do i take my city i have
a local economy how do i plug it into
the bitcoin network taking your salary
in bitcoin is actually like the easiest
simplest
least important thing you can do it's a
signal it's the bat signals the flag in
the ground but it doesn't change
anything for anybody else right it's
just simply saying hey i believe in this
stuff what does change things change the
tax regime go ahead and actually start
to use some of your electricity or power
generation to mine bitcoin right create
some sort of environment where you can
actually educate people on the
technology how can they build companies
do something where uh like in kentucky
they've actually said if you use
kentucky power to mine bitcoin there was
a legislative proposal i don't know if
it got passed or not but they were
saying that you would get better uh tax
treatment if you use kentucky power to
mine bitcoin rather than if you went
somewhere else so you start to do that
now all of a sudden you're using
economic incentives to get more people
to move there and also you're gonna get
the economic benefit of plugging in it's
not just a oh look what i did and so the
last thing we've got here is uh francis
suarez of miami he has this quote where
he said mayor adams and i have become
great friends and i welcome the friendly
competition i think it's incredible that
he's joined me in leading american
cities on cryptocurrency and helping
democratize the financial system not
just for new yorkers and miamians but
for every american and i think that you
know one uh obviously funny he joined me
right yeah
legendary
i got it right
he's good at what he does let's be clear
he's good at what he does uh but but i
do think that there's this entire
element of now when you have new york
and miami doing it there's other cities
that if you don't get in the game if
you're not even trying to compete does
that actually work against you like it
was okay to sit it out because nobody
else was in so then all of a sudden
there was nothing it's like oh all
cities are doing this but the second you
get one and two three big cities to say
hey we're in
now if you sit out it almost becomes the
opportunity cause of sitting it out is
so obvious to everyone that that's a
negative versus actually participating
right